I think of course there is lame when it
comes to women you have made a choice to
have sex without a condom 100 you have
allowed religion or whatever societal
cultural influences affect how you feel
in terms of abortion or contraception or
whatever but I still feel like if you're
having sex with a man and he says I
don't want to have a condom and you're
like you know what okay fine I don't
want to have a condom evil but he also
chose not to use a content if I ask you
a question I'm gonna ask you a question
okay so say all right say you have sex
and you get pregnant who controls who
gives birth who whose choice is that
what what after you're pregnant who
whose choice is it I have a question for
you do you know I need to answer that
question that's fine I can do that okay
yeah women give birth cool no no no no
who's in control of whether you keep it
or give birth yeah that's fine okay I
agree with that of course you have a
baby so you agree that women have more
who have control over who is born